hi everybody i just finished a really
long and wide-ranging conversation with
michael saylor
who's been in the news a lot because of
his
really prescient forays into the world
of blockchain and bitcoin specifically
he's the chairman founder
president of microstrategy
which is a technology company in its own
right but has
been very very deep as an exponent
proponent of
blockchain not only for you know
personal
uh gains but really to improve the world
as you'll hear about he really wants to
use
his wealth that he's gaining to educate
everybody on earth for free that's
really his mission sounds crazy
but i think he could do it and uh and i
like that he has an engineering uh
approach to things he thinks about
things he constantly references the
second law of thermodynamics so he's got
to be good
in this physicist book we talked about a
lot of things including science fiction
arthur c clarke
what he'd put in his ethical will i
think you're gonna love it uh
please leave a comment in the in the
section below we're gonna make our
you know kind of investment pioneers
playlist with jim simons
bill perkins patrick bet david and now
with michael saylor he agreed to come
back on a part two someday
so look forward to that put comments for
him in the future
please sit back enjoy this
next episode of into the impossible with
michael saylor and made me think that
maybe they should be giving out nobel
prizes instead of in gold like this one
here
but in bitcoin blockchain no who knows
it could it could go down
who knows what's going to happen this is
not investment advice i wish i could buy
a bitcoin but for now
i'm taking his advice to at least
investigate it and not view it with as
much
derision as i confess i did before so
enjoy this episode
of the into the impossible podcast and
like comment subscribe do all those cool
things that you're supposed to do
and it keeps the podcast going and ad
free otherwise i'm going to be doing
stuff for like
bitcoin and ethereum and
bird no litecoin anyway don't make me
resort to that please uh
help me out and uh leave your tiny
contribution the form of a review or a
or a thumbs up thank you very much enjoy
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so it is a pleasure to welcome to the
into the impossible podcast
none other than michael saylor who is
joining us today
uh to talk about a whole host of things
not only
bitcoin uh and the uh the splash that
he's made
lately but but also his wonderful book
that we will get into as well which is
really prescient for
uh for predicting many things not the
least of which is
is how mobile technology would uh impact
the planet and my question for him is
how can we use new technologies like
blockchain
like mobile uh connectivity 5g
etc to improve the world and improve
perhaps the prosperity of the world i
think that is a major theme of michael's
work so
michael how are you today awesome thanks
for having me brian
yeah it's great pleasure to have you on
the into the impossible podcast so
i uh i was really intrigued by
you know many of the conversations i've
seen you have uh and oftentimes they
relate to
interests of mine aviation i'm a private
pilot
i am interested in the ash uh of you
know act being an astronaut
and i know you are mit trained in
engineering
we've had on a lot of professors and
alum
uh fellow beavers from mit lately max
tegmark who's a current
professor there noam chomsky has been on
the show
we've had on peter diamandis who is a
graduate of mit
and david kaiser who's a professor there
we're a very close connection
despite the distance but the first thing
i want to talk to you about today
uh is your book which is called the
mobile wave and
i always say i disregard the advice to
not judge books by their covers
i always judge books by their covers how
did you come up with the cover design
and the name and the title of the book
and the subtitle what was the impetus
behind those choices that you made
the idea behind the book was
there's a there's a new wave of uh
software engineering
we're moving from the mainframe era
to the mini computer error that was the
second wave the third wave was
the pc error the fourth wave was the
internet wave
the fifth wave was the mobile wave
when software dematerializes
it jumps off of laptops it jumps off of
desktops it jumps onto mobile devices
and it becomes like vapor and it
envelops the entire world
and so i mean the cover of the book was
based upon the idea that software was
going to spread
everywhere in the world and and
transform
the civilization
i was uh i was kind of excited about it
because
i lived through the phase of software
being trapped
on a desktop pc and the internet way was
still
delivered largely through pcs but when
we got to the
to the iphone 3 and it was clear that
the iphone was not a toy anymore
and that the ios and android were going
to be new operating systems
that were going to rise to parity with
the web
and maybe superiority to the web
i think it changed the nature of
software it
software changed from being something
uh something we went to do we we went to
use the software tool
on a desk and then software became
clothing it became fashion accessory it
became
it became in the air it became stuff we
smell
it it became stuff we wear it became it
became things we
sleep with you sleep with your sulfur
and
at the point that we were wearing it and
sleeping with it and living with
it and crying and laughing with it
uh the nature changed and the type of
software you would want to build change
and what you could do with it changed
and that was just
transformational to the companies that
were doing it
to the computer industry to the
civilization and i thought it merited a
book and so i
i got kind of excited about writing that
book with the
alums that i mentioned i'll also mention
andy viturbi
who is a graduate of mit
his book over here in my office which
has a slightly more stark cover than
your book does
zero colors whatsoever besides this
orange type of color
and in it he's recounting sort of his
journey as an entrepreneur as a refugee
coming to america and then founding you
know discovering the the viterbi
algorithm
and really converting you know
intellectual property
into uh into into technology
and of course we use that today in cdma
we use it in 5g
and my question is you know first of all
you know in
in retrospect uh is this mobile what
would be the i don't know i lost track
of how many waves we're at
under your taxonomy system but uh but
sixth wave seventh wave
five it was it was the fifth starting
from the mainframe mini computer pc
internet and then mobile
so peter diamandis has said he uses
these famous five d's presumably because
his name has d so many d's in it
you know but uh democratization d
materialism
uh then there's but exponential which is
an e but but anyway
uh d what do you see is the six wave is
it is it something
completely different than these other
waves is it is it a rogue wave
that we really can't anticipate right
now
well first of all as a disclaimer peter
is a fraternity brother of mine we were
the same fraternity he was four years
ahead of me at mit
and uh quite my role model and we both
had a love of
uh of aerospace engineering and rocket
science and astronautics and the lake
yes and uh so i've i've uh
gleefully followed steve's peter's
career for the entire time period
um the sixth wave is the virtual wave
i mean the mobile wave was software
you know look software on the desktop
was bottled up
to uh to the white collar labor
force an hour two hours a day and if you
could
sit down at a desk you could work with
your spreadsheet or your word
processor or your accounting system on a
computer
but it was a white collar
constrained functionality
when software leaked to a mobile device
it went from 500 million people using it
two hours a day
to five billion people soon to be
everybody
five billion people that could use it 16
hours a day and maybe 24 hours a day
arguably right because
the software could wake you up in the
middle of the night and so you went to
724
365 software coverage for
everybody on the planet which meant that
three-year-olds were using
software and 75 year olds were using
software
whereas the software of the of the
internet
and the and the pc error was primarily
well to do white collar laborers and
and and the affluent uh companies
at their desks and so so the potential
to have software that
that interrupted your and impacted your
recreation and your social life
you know software to drive a car
software to book a restaurant
or a hotel reservation software to pay
bills
software to take photos right all of
that was mobile wave software you
wouldn't have
done anything with your friends while
you're at your desk at three in the
afternoon
so the mobile wave was software leaping
off of the desktop and out of the office
and
into the world of the teenager
and on a saturday afternoon and that's
what made for a facebook
or an amazon uh mobile you know
or google or youtube you know and laid
the laid the framework for entertainment
and
and communications but now um
now we're moving on the virtual wave and
the virtual wave probably has two
primary
um uh primary significant dynamics
one you're seeing the virtualization
of a whole class of products and
services
that previously were delivered uh by
human beings
so like uh that you can zoom anywhere at
the speed of light and bend time and
space
if i'm a sales person i can take 40
sales calls a week
if i want in 40 different cities
and so the complete dematerialization
and virtualization of
of sales and marketing and services and
all of the cycles and energy expended to
do that
that's one element and by the way
that phrase you can zoom anywhere at the
speed of light and bend time and space
put a period on it it's a very important
powerful phrase because the second part
of the phrase and bend time and space
well it refers to the fact that i can
zoom to 40 places in 40 to
40 different cities and have 40 meetings
and be one person and i can be
not in the office so that's pretty
profound but the other profound part of
it is
what you just did when we started our
call which is you punch the record
button
and you and i are having a meeting
cross country and that's about to be
shared with
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people
anywhere anytime
three years from now someone will be
able to go back in time
three years and be in the room with us
now
for the cost of electricity and so if
you think about it that way and turn it
on his head
i'm a salesperson and uh
i think well i'm gonna convince you you
should buy my product brian
and you asked me a hundred questions
well how does it work with google
and i give you the answer and i think
after the fact man i was pretty
articulate
when i sold to brian i think i'll take
that video meeting
and i'll upload it to my website and
i'll let the next 9 700
customers with the same requirement
watch the video and you can do
transcripts you can do highlighting you
can do
conversion and languages in real time
with ai
i do that and i multi-purpose all the i
mean
not this particular conversation i
certainly will have an ai generated
transcript from it you're absolutely
right
so it scales in a way that ordinary
telecons never could
you ever see uh the watchmen the movie
they're watching with dr manhattan
okay so dr manhattan is like this
guy who can make a hundred versions of
himself
now what if you could you know what if i
could speak with you
and then i could deliver it in a hundred
thousand places at the same
time and now you just blew my mind in 27
languages
yeah so it's it sounds godlike right
it's god-like power
you can bend time and space but you're
kind of like uh
a hundred years ago if you'd said mike
i'm gonna take every sales meeting in
every language in real time but i'm
going to do it
a hundred thousand times faster than the
ordinary mortal
or a million times faster you would say
no
that's impossible but the virtual wave
means that yeah you can basically have
god-like power
bend time and space and you can do
things inconceivable
in ways inconceivable so that that's the
first part of it but
that's the virtualization of the p l of
every company
like the way you you sell your product
market your product deliver your service
has been virtualized and you can
when you virtualize it you make it
possible to be a million times more
efficient
and there are profound implications we
could talk about those we why won't now
but there are profound implications to
how you compete and create value in
society but there's another part to the
virtual wave which is
we're watching the virtualization of
money
and the virtualization of gold and store
of value
300 trillion dollars worth of money in
the world
is stored in cash gold
bonds real estate stocks
they're all 20th century instruments
most of them are fiat instruments
they're they're tied to underlying cash
flows
and this new thing we call bitcoin
has evolved and bitcoin is
digital scarcity it's 21 million gold
coins sitting in cyberspace you can't
make any more
running on a decentralized set of nodes
no human being no ceo no company no
government can stop it from running no
one can screw with it it's going to be
21 million
for the next thousand years quite likely
and that 21 million uh
cyber coins bitcoin can now
capture the monetary energy off of gold
silver bonds stocks real estate indexes
and as we speak you're seeing that
monetary energy
dematerialize and and morph
into what is in essence virtual gold and
uh that virtual monetary network
is growing this year 300 percent
every year for the last decade 200
percent
it's building it's building it's
building and it's virtualizing entire
balance sheets of companies
and it's virtualizing treasuries of
individuals
and there's no reason to think it'll
stop for a decade because
because um a virtual gold coin
or virtual gold bar on the bitcoin
network
has no mass it can move at the speed of
light
it's a million times better than an
actual gold bar
a million times smarter a million times
faster a million times
stronger a million times harder than an
actual goal
bar just like you can speak to a million
people
in a dozen languages you're a million
times more persuasive
as the virtual teacher and so what we've
got
is is a next generation money
and a next generation set of uh
actors in the virtual wave that are
virtualizing everything
and that's going to dominate our you
know our society for the next decade
that transformation now i want to push
back with respect
and say that um do you do you know
so i'm holding up a golden medallion
this is a replica of the nobel prize
uh that one of my nobel prize winning
guests left on my couch over here
uh no it's actually just a fake piece of
chocolate that i have left over from
hanukkah
but uh i'll believe whatever you tell me
honestly i know i know that's your
reputation extremely agreeable
um on the side of these coins and you'll
find this on quarters
and dimes but you won't find it on
nickels or pennies there are these
ridges do you know what the purpose of
those ridges are do you know what those
are called i've always uh
been curious if you're i i thought
they're there to keep people from like
shaving the coins or something that's
right that's exactly
right that was create exactly so it's a
way that since roman times people were
doing what's called coin clipping
and they would shave down just a little
bit of the coin and that was a way that
they could
accumulate over enough of these coins
they could accumulate a full coin
so they were actually devaluing their
money and the romans knew about this
no one solved it until a man by the name
of isaac newton
came about and actually led to a great
deal of catastrophe especially in the
jewish community of england in the 1200s
that were basically expelled
uh from england for vehement suspicion
of
of uh committing committing this type of
monetary fraud and and so forth of
course it wasn't true
and then later when isaac newton became
master of the mint
he said well put these ridges on it now
the reason that we have it on quarters
is because as you know a quarter used to
be a quarter ounce of silver
but a penny was always uh you know it
doesn't have the ridges because it's
made of a base metal more base metal
it there's no profit in shaving down a
penny versus a silver
coin of course now there's no silver in
our currency
in america but the notion that this had
to occur
uh was because of the scarcity of gold
so i can tell you that
gold that i have and if this were a real
nobel prize it would be worth
about 24 000 and uh and that gold came
from
the collision of two enormous neutron
stars
and that happened perhaps five billion
years ago in our region of the galaxy
and the neutron enrichment basically a
giant atom not a 56
neutron but 10 to the 56 neutrons or
something like that
coming together the shrapnel of which
produced the gold
and that we find now you're saying we're
only going to have
you know 21 million coins that are
subdivided into so many satoshis or what
bitcoin
but i don't think there's going to be
another neutron star that
put it this way if another neutron star
collides near the earth we've got much
bigger problems in our monetary
situation but you know the fact is
that's much more scarce than
my friend down the street minds bitcoin
in other words how can we be so certain
that it is it has this permanence and it
has this durability
and resilience that makes it a true
store of money the way that these
neutron stars did for us
many billions of years ago
the history of money is is human beings
looking
for some for some system that they can
use to store and trade value both with
each other and with themself over time
and we've used sea shells and we've used
glass beads and
we've used gold and silver and copper
and
we've used paper that represents gold
and wave u
and we've used fiat and
we are we're moving toward using bitcoin
um in terms of scarcity commodity money
is when i use cattle i mean i trade you
cattle or i trade you wheat by the way
the early americans they use tobacco
right that was
you know i i still do and
they couldn't get money from the brits
and so they actually traded bales of
tobacco
the problem with commodities is that
as the price goes up human
ingenuity and technology is incentivized
to produce more of it
right if if i can do a thing if if i
double the price
of tobacco right then i'm going to go
someone's going to
far more tobacco right if i use wood
i'll
create more wood with some commodities
they're really easy to produce
the hardest commodity to produce
that also had the characteristics that
we wanted for money was gold
i mean because we needed it to be
durable and stable like it needs to
it needs to last a thousand years right
some tobacco doesn't last a thousand
years right so
so some things are hard to produce but
they're not stable at room temperature
and not malleable other things are very
stable but they're not hard enough to
produce
you know some some things aren't
subdividable something
you know i have to be able to you know i
can tell that's gold
maybe easier than i can just distinguish
certain other metals
so mankind pred decided upon gold
but at the end of the day
anything that that is man-made we can
produce more of it so we
we mine gold gold miners produce about
two percent more gold every year
and on average that's been going on for
as long as anybody can remember
that means that if i took all of all of
the money in the world and i bought
gold with it and i had 100 of the gold
in the world
100 years from now i would have 12 and a
half percent of the gold in the world
so so if i'm using gold as a store of
value
then i'm going to have a 2 inflation
rate due to gold mining
um if i use by with oil as a store of
value
when oil prices were 30 40 a barrel you
know we ended up fighting gulf wars and
we went off to the gulf to fight a war
because we were afraid that the price of
oil would go too
too high there'd be an oil shortage
eventually the price of oil went to 100
a barrel and there were billions of
dollars of capital flow
from the big banks into the frackers
and then oil entrepreneurs like
chesapeake enemy
started fracking oil and the oil
production in the u.s went from 5
million barrels a day to 10 million
barrels a day in five years
and it had not changed in 50 years and
so conventional wisdom-wise we had an
oil shortage
enough conventional wisdom we would
fight a war over it i mean that's that's
pretty strong conviction
but in fact we didn't have an oil
shortage uh what we had was
a price that was too low to justify
human ingenuity and capital solving the
problem
and uh and we have the same challenge
with commodity money like gold
if the price of gold stays about the
constant level
two thousand dollars an ounce you can
expect that the amount
of gold that gets mined will be two
percent more a year and it's it's fairly
predictable
but if the price of gold were to go to
twenty thousand dollars an ounce
then you have um you have three perverse
incentives to make gold uh
a risky bet one is ten times as much
incentive for gold miners produce gold
so they'll be more capital equipment
they'll go faster
they're going to prove out the reserves
faster they're going to
work at a higher rate and uh they will
invent new
new chemistries and new technologies to
mine gold if they have 10x the incentive
to do it
pretty much all those smart mit grads
they come out of school and they take
the job that pays them the most so if
you want to double the salary of
mining engineers you'll get all the
smartest people in the world they'll be
trying to do it
that's the first challenge the second
challenge is
a lot of gold is centralized which means
uh
you can hypothecate it and you can sell
it short
there's no way for you to be sure that
the bank that holds all your gold
didn't actually sell the gold twice
without telling you
because you can't reasonably withdraw
100 million dollars of gold and stored
underneath your mattress
but and so that means that gold has
always been plagued
by people issuing notes against the gold
without enough gold to cover it
the most famous example being nixon
going off the gold standard in 1971 when
the united states printed more dollars
than they had gold to back it and they
had to actually default on that promise
but it's not the only example i mean the
last 2000 years is the history of all
sorts of regimes the romans debased
their currency
and they they cut back the number of
grams and gold coins and
and uh uh this denurturing the denarius
is part of the reason for the fall of
the roman empire
all sorts of monarchs in middle east
medieval
you know europe used to issue credit
notes and the like
backed by gold and when they over issued
them they couldn't make good on it then
they
they also were ruined most
most countries have this issue over time
the
u.s had it and
you have it today you have lots of
examples of banks selling gold short
a naked short without the without the uh
the gold
to back it and even nation states
do it and can do it to manipulate the
price however they want
so it's a corruptable thing and finally
it can be seized
because if you buy enough gold it has to
be centralized in a certain few volts
and it's very expensive to move
it's not practical for a hundred million
people
to take personal custody of their gold
whereas if you look at something like
bitcoin bitcoin is audited every 10
minutes
by 10 000 nodes so it's very it's very
challenging and not impossible to lie
about it
those hundred million people can take
personal custody if they want
because it has no mass and
if the price goes to a billion you can't
make any more of it
the reason it's scarce is because the
protocol
you know by the way we have other scarce
things in the world for example
conservation of energy is this you know
the first law of thermodynamics and the
second and third
and close thermodynamic systems they all
operate based on scarcity or
conservation of energy
and mathematics is based upon the idea
that two plus two equals four
not five and not three i mean
mathematics is
conservative in that regard you take
away
conservative engineering your boats
don't float
your airplanes won't fly pneumatic and
hydraulic systems don't work
electrical engineering systems fail if
you don't have a closed system
the leak destroys them all so
bitcoin is engineered it's an engineered
monetary network
it is a closed system the reason it's
closed is because the protocol
closed it you there's nothing that that
um
there's no law that says you had to
write code to make a crypto network
conservative
they there are crypto networks where
they actually inflate
the money supply or inflate the token
supply every year
there are some that don't have a limit
on it right um
bitcoin happens to be a conservative
crypto network because it was designed
to be that deflationary currency
they could have built a two percent
inflation rate into it it would have
been perfectly light gold right
right but they put a zero percent
inflation rate over
the long period of time i mean once you
accept the fact there's a 21 million
coin cap and then the thing that
actually makes it
truly scarce is uh two dynamics
um the first order second order dynamic
the first autodynamic
is it's a decentralized network running
on thousands of nodes
and no one node can change the consensus
and so it's impossible to change the way
the network
works without taking over the entire
network which is decentralized with
massive inertia
so if you held a gun to my head i
couldn't do it if i wanted to
no country could no company can no
engineer can
and so that's that's why i mean that is
really the
essence of crypto this uh this idea of a
truly decentralized ethos and bitcoin is
pro
is the greatest example of a truly
successful decentralized
crypto network but the second the second
order
thing that keeps from being scarce is
you could
you could that you could copy it you
could clone it the argument is what if i
just clone it and create bitcoin cash
bitcoin gold bitcoin satoshi vision
bitcoin version 42.
cinematic universe 2947
it's like they keep creating more
universes right parallel universes
you know if you're a comic book fan and
finally like would in what universe does
like the wolverine die
or not i forget you know you get lost
that's the problem with cloning the
reason it doesn't work with money
but it got tried it's failed seven
thousand eight thousand
times it's because once
there's a massive network effect and
it's not just metcalfe's law metcalfe's
law
is an imperfect model it's more like
metcalfe's law
with a bunch of newtonian astrophysics
thrown in there
it's gravitation gravitational
uh energy on a network because
when a hundred million people join the
network
of course they're going to resist any
other network
but when 20 of those 100 million people
have a billion each
and they join the network they resist
with a billion times the force
and so as people with billions and
billions of dollars and as
companies join the network like square
like paypal
like uh like 25 billionaires that have
done it this year
when they join the network they join it
with a billion times as much
gravitational pull like i i used to joke
you know rupert murdoch never brought a
billion friends to facebook
right but uh rupert murdoch would bring
a billion dollars to bitcoin
and so this network has a gravitational
effect and it's like
it's like why is it that you don't fly
off of the earth onto the asteroid to
cross the earth and the answer is
because gravity
because there's more mass beneath you
you know
then then then the gravitational pull of
the asteroid flying
out there you're not going to fly off of
the earth
what you're going to have is all of the
asteroids to get near the earth they get
sucked into our gravity well
and what's happening now is that
monetary energy is being sucked into the
monetary energy well
of bitcoin and you could clone it a
million times they're all
you know take a rock and throw it up in
the air and see whether it keeps going
that direction
or it comes back down to earth you know
you could toss it a million times it's
not escaping
you know the gravity well because you've
got a million times more
gravitational pull down than you have up
and that's what's going on with bitcoin
it's past the event horizon
and it's getting power more and more
powerful because of this uh
this uh energy dynamic as brian keating
back with you just taking a pause to
refresh in this episode of the into the
impossible podcast with today's
phenomenal guest michael saylor
asking you to subscribe to the channel
on youtube leave a like thumbs up a
comment
a question for michael for next time
he's agreed to come back on
if you're on itunes listening to this
please leave me a small asterism
a constellation of stars from one to
five
those are the options i read every
review i take them all to heart
discuss them with my therapist and it
really uh is the only thing i ask of you
i'm not taking advertisements as you
know
and so the only remuneration i expect is
one bitcoin per now i
only expect or hope wish
that you would leave me a review on
itunes or wherever you're listening to
this podcast like subscribe please share
it
and please go to my website
briankeating.com you're going to get
the 10 life lessons i learned from jim
simons if you sign up for my mailing
list so please do that as well
and that will really benefit me and who
knows we could do a part two in the ten
life lessons i learned from michael
saylor but you only get that
if you subscribe to my newsletter
briankeating.com i hope you enjoy this
episode of the into the impossible
podcast
if all other money were sound if gold
was not inflating
you know two percent doubling every 36
years of supply
if uh if uh us dollar wasn't inflating
if we were all on some kind of hard
current would bitcoin still be rising
yeah but it would be r but it would be
growing because it's superior technology
so there are three dynamics here right
there's there's adoption
the the rate of adoption which is a
marketing evangelical
thing then there's the improvement in
technical utility
what can i do with the money and then
the
the third thing is the inflation right
so let's take gold if i couldn't make
any
more gold if i agreed that their 21
million gold bars
and their 21 million gold bitcoin
bitcoin would still be better because it
has no mass and it moves at the speed of
light so i can move 100 million of
bitcoin
for a nickel to tokyo but i'd it would
cost me 250 000
in a month to move 100 million in gold
to tokyo
so i can build bitcoin into square cash
and i can buy it
in one click in one second but i can't
buy
ten thousand dollars of gold in one
click in one second
so the technical utility would still be
superior
even if there was no inflation of gold
yeah i would say the efficiency i mean
gold is used in the technology that
you're using to transport the
electrons across at the speed near near
the speed of light
so i mean intrinsic value i think i i
would i would agree that gold
is is more is less efficient and
therefore the velocity in which it can
be transported
obviously as much lower as you're right
you can't take delivery i talked to jim
simons we're going to get to jim simons
um who is another mit grad and he said
you know one of the things he used to
worry about is one of his future
contracts if he went the wrong way he'd
have
800 head of steer in the parking lot at
renaissance technology and
they're not a cattle farm so you know
there are benefits of it there are
disadvantages of it but
when we when you talk about the
technology uh you know i haven't
delved into it probably as much as i
should but but it seems to me that
technology was in place decades ago in
other words you could have a blockchain
type
you could i mean it wouldn't it wouldn't
be operate with the efficiency
it wouldn't maybe have you know as many
nodes and
network law the law of network effects
you know stephen shruggets a friend of
mine who wrote the definitive paper
about network theory with 32 000
citations in nature
and this is about the exponential
geometric growth of networks growing as
the number of squares of nodes
so yes it would have fewer nodes maybe
but what is there any
physical law that would have precluded
bitcoin's adoption in 1987 or you know
earlier than this rise in the last
decade or so
i have a phrase my phrase is technology
fails until it succeeds and that
generally describes all paradigm shifts
it describes the airplane for a thousand
years people tried to fly and then they
you know wright brothers figured it out
but by
if they didn't have an internal
combustion engine they wouldn't have
flown
right it describes mobile phones people
tried and they
and and the breakthrough was like
sufficiently powerful lithium-ion
batteries
you know and and certain chips and some
of some of these uh
you know codecs right um
uh compression algorithms yeah so there
are a few things we needed
in every single industry there's uh
there's always some thing that you need
in order to break through to the next
level
with uh with the launch of bitcoin
we've been working on the technologies
for about 40 years previous
i mean uh and it's well documented you
know proof of work
you needed pretty good pretty good
privacy i mean public
private key encryption and proof-of-work
algorithms
you know and you you needed sufficiently
powerful
cpu chips and there was some there is
some math
involved and uh people tried it uh they
launched a number of them hash cash and
e-gold
in the decade previous this wasn't the
first attempt
bitcoin was the first attempt that was
successful
okay so so they probably attempted it i
don't know a dozen two dozen
times before and they worked on
different elements of it for
for 10 to 20 even 30 years before
it was bound to happen at some point
when you had a critical mass
of network computers computational power
encryption algorithms and they just put
all the pieces together
and that's what bitcoin was and then it
took you know it took 10 years
of they started a fire in cyberspace it
took 10 years of the fire burning
for it to get big enough that it would
work through
all of its risk factors and it would
mature enough
that an institution would be willing to
actually put hundreds of millions of
dollars
of capital on it right like
the early exchanges got hacked like
mount cox
maybe the irs could have destroyed it
with the wrong tax treatment
if they didn't give it the right tax
treatment um it did get
cloned people weren't sure how the forks
would you know would work out they need
it needed to be attacked in every which
way
for it to mature and season
and as it got more mature then more
energy got put into it and then it got
tempered then it got stronger
and as it got stronger it you know it
went from
a bunch of visionary retailers
and you know a motley crew of traders
and hackers and retailers and true
believers and technologists
and speculators and then it eventually
rotated into
institutions looking for a an an
investment grade safe haven asset but it
took a while to get there and it took
not just ten years of of uh of it
it living and uh competing for space
and getting hardened but it also took
the covid crisis
and the pandemic of 2020 because that
was a catalyst right
march of 2020 was a catalyst for the
explosion of zoom
and virtual work and it was an it was a
catalyst for the explosion of bitcoin
because you simultaneously had a billion
people
that needed a solution to a problem and
that was the that was the platform that
would solve the problem
at the point that they needed it and
they couldn't delay any longer yeah
i want to get back to covid in the
context of risk management so
i run uh with my colleagues a very large
telescope
array complex that we are building in
the high atacama desert of chile
and we're responsible for almost
everything called the simon's
observatory
and we're responsible for you know
bringing concrete and diesel fuel and
generators and
but also the very delicate
superconducting uh
sensors that detect this wispy glow of
photons that we call the cosmic
microwave background radiation and so
we've got you know very fine skills it's
kind of like into
like a the biathlon like sometimes you
have to be very very
you know control your breath and focus
on these ultra precise things and
sometimes you just gotta haul butt
and get you know just get concrete up
the mountain um so we have these things
called risk registers and we go over
them and what kind of things could
compromise the project let's brainstorm
where are the flaws in our logic uh that
could come up with it now
you know these are the most brilliant
people in the world these are members of
the national academy of sciences people
they
are shortlisted for the nobel prize so
to speak
not a one of us had global pandemic to
shut down all supply chains
in chile where the telescope is located
in every you know state in america where
all our collaborators work every country
around the world that we have colleagues
on every one of the seven continents
shut down um and uh and manufacturing of
the telescope large equip
no one had coveted what is you know
when i think about it uh you know i once
you try to send a message to
your good friend peter schiff on twitter
you know i said you know one of the
problems with with
gold and he's the most notorious gold
bug i think in the world
he didn't ever answered me by the way
but uh but but you know it's like
eventually you have to convert it to
dollars like event
in order to do anything with it you have
to convert it to one of these inferior
according to you and many and to him
certainly uh inferior medium media of
exchange or stores of value
um so the fact that to me represents a
possible existential risk because right
now
yeah the irs is maybe not treating it we
saw something ripple last couple weeks
as far as i i know i don't follow it
very closely
but um but what's to prevent you know a
really black swan event as
tele would say from you know government
just saying
you're this is now illegal and any
proceeds we want to know the history of
every single coin
and unless you prove have proof of that
work and proof of where the coin came
from and it never touched a black market
dealership whatever what's to stop that
from happening
um you know or and or do you see other
potential covid esque risks that could
compromise
the rosy story of it growing 200 per
year
i i just think that's fairly de minimis
like
it's been growing 200 a year every year
for the past 11
years and you're only going to have 30
years of your life in business so how
long are you going to stare at something
which is a screaming successful thing
in denial peter schiff has been against
bitcoin for 10 years
he'd be a billionaire right now he'd be
a 10 billionaire right now
if he'd actually not been against it you
would lose
by resisting it you would lose 98 to 99
of your wealth over five years if you're
in denial of this thing so
there's a cost to being a denial uh of
stuff um let me
let me just again offer an example
you know like if you're on an airplane
and somebody puts their elbow through a
window
and it starts depressurizing
and the auction gets sucked out of the
airplane and then the oxygen mass drops
down from the compartment above
are you going to stare at it and debate
with me for like two hours about all the
black swans and whether or not the
oxygen is safe and
whether or not you should breathe the
oxygen or whether or not you should not
breathe
are you going to put the mask on like
because it's new you've never used an
oxygen mask in an
airplane before if i take you and i drop
you in the middle of the
you know the ocean and you're 50 feet
down with the weight
around your neck and i hand you scuba
equipment and a regular
are you going to put it in your mouth
are you going to debate with me
and you're going to ask me to twist and
try to what if it's possible that some
politician in some country
passes some law making it illegal for me
to put this regulator in my mouth
it's like we're really reaching hard
here to find a reason to not
do the obvious i want to give you
another metaphor you're at the top of
the north pole it's 70 degrees we're all
playing frisbee
there's one heated igloo on the north
pole
there's a guy at the front door he
charges tick admission and you can buy a
ticket for a dollar
you don't need the ticket you like it
outside and then some politician turns
down the temperature 10 degrees
and the ticket price goes to 10 oh you
still keep playing no big deal
and then some politician turns on the
temperature another 10 degrees
and the ticket price goes to a hundred
dollars and you're like i don't know i'm
not sure i mean what's in that igloo it
might be kind of dangerous in that igloo
i think i'll just start
so another politician turns to the
temperature another 10 degrees
and you're afraid of the igloo it's dark
in there maybe it isn't dark and maybe
the food's not so good and i turn it
down another 10 degrees
when it gets to zero degrees and you're
in t-shirt and you start
getting bone chilled the temperature the
price is going to go to a hundred
thousand dollars to get in
and you still don't know whether or not
you can get in but every intelligent
person you know
walk through the door before you and
they're fine
waving at you saying it's warm in here
you're gonna freeze to death brian
and you're still standing there and the
guy cranks the temperature down and
there's a peter schiff standing next to
you going
i don't think you should go into that
heated igloo because
it's possible the politicians will pass
a law making it illegal
or taxing you on that heated igloo and
then the politician
cranks it down to minus 40 below and
peter schiff is still
telling you man i don't know if it's
safe in that igloo and all your friends
are saying
brian you idiot why don't you come in
here and stop
freezing to death it's fine here you're
gonna die
and some dude is still gonna yeah i know
but they haven't done anything for 14
years but i i don't think i've never
been in an igloo before i'm afraid
and the point is every time
the fed or a banker prints 10 or 15
percent more currency
they are sucking 15 of the energy
out of the financial system that's the
same as sucking 15
of the oxygen out of your room that's
the same as lowering the temperature
10 degrees when i suck the energy
out of an adiabatic system you have heat
laps
you will freeze to death if you don't
suffocate
we have a currency collapse going on
right now
the only difference is it's going it was
going on at five percent a year in the
us
now it's going on at 25 percent this
year
it's going to go on 15 for the next five
years
same in europe it's collapsing at a
faster rate in argentina venezuela
brazil
nigeria south africa turkey
lebanon fill in the blank
you can stand there living in fear that
someone might hypothetically ask you
to stop freezing to or you know get out
of the igloo
but on the other hand there's a hundred
percent likelihood
you're going to freeze to death if you
stand where you are and do nothing 100
there's a one percent likelihood that
when you
actually move into the heated igloo
something unexpected is going to happen
that you did not anticipate
or perhaps someone will object but
you'll be warm
and that is that is the situation with
bitcoin right now which is
a lot of people are working very hard to
come up with some reason
why they shouldn't trust a new thing
meanwhile it's quite clear
that 7.8 billion people on the planet
have a problem
everybody with money on earth is going
to lose half their wealth in the next 48
months
if they do nothing if you live if you're
one of the billion people in a
collapsing developed economy
you're going to lose everything if you
do nothing the solution
is a digital monetary network that
doesn't dissipate
energy that you can access where where
no one can corrupt it and you can take
personal custody of your money
of your monetary energy yes there's
uncertainty
for the first time in human history we
invented the thing
it's new but it's not one year new it's
11 years
12 years old and you don't have to put
100 by the way when the oxygen mass
drops out of the plane and you're
traveling with your 10 kids
are you going to put the mask on one kid
to see if they live
and let the other nine kids suffocate or
are you going to put the mask on
everybody or you can put your mask on
yourself first
how afraid are you of suffocating versus
how afraid are you
of using the oxygen because bitcoin is
oxygen and it's new
and there's some people there are some
people that are very comfortable
in their existence and they think it's
okay to ignore it because they're rich
and they're comfortable and they're
happy there are some people that dabble
in it like i think i'll buy one or two
percent
because it i'll speculate in it and
there are some people like if i put you
in argentina and
i by the way do you know the exchange
rate in argentina to the dollar right
now
no i know it's inflating tremendously
it used to be one peso to the dollar
and then it slid to 10 pesos to the
dollar and then it slid to 20 pesos
you know they actually write on it they
actually change they just cross it out
and add con
zeros and con i had a guest on and it
slid to 40 pesos to the dollar
then it slid to 80 pesos to the dollar
the black market rate is 140
pesos to the dollar and the dollar has
lost half of its value in the 10 years
so you've actually lost what is one
divided by
280 it's like
if you're living in argentina and you
have any wealth to speak of
you lost 99 of it
now right are we going to sit and think
about
ways that we might hype it's
hypothetically possible that a
politician in argentina will pass a law
requiring that i disclose my bitcoin or
tax it or whatever
but are you going to suffocate your
entire family and destroy
everything you know based on the
hypothetical possibility that someone
might object
to you choosing to not roll over and die
because it seems like most of the world
would like for us just all
roll over and die and shut up and not
make a big stink about it it seems to me
that if i come into your house and i
start cranking the temperature down
until i freeze your children
at some point maybe you'll have the
bravery
to open the back door and walk into
the backyard and maybe go find a new
house
i mean like it's just a matter of
courage
and maturity at some point and for those
people that just want to
spread fear and uncertainty and doubt i
mean
like what's the future for humanity if
we're going to live in
fear of the solution to the problem that
plagues us
all i had on that's a very good uh point
michael i had on
lord martin reece who is uh the
astronomer royal
which uh does not mean that he tells the
queen her horoscope he tells me
but uh but he is in fact in charge of
all the observatories in england at
least uh
officially but he has the position that
uh
isaac newton had back in 1700s which is
master of trinity college
and and he said to me well you know the
thing that disturbed because he writes
many books about the future
in fact he has his new book is called on
the future and i'll put a link to that
in this podcast as well he's a brilliant
guy futurist i don't know if you've ever
heard of him
uh but um but he says that blockchain
kind of depresses him
because it's a sign of distrust it's a
sign that people don't trust each other
and
we're gonna show how trustworthy we are
by
you know completely exposing and
transparentizing
every aspect of this particular type of
uh of of commodity or of currency or of
store of value however you want to
describe it
but um but i pointed out that that's
basically you know what's
what's written as you've all know noah
harari points out you know
on each dollar bill it says in god we
trust like we're not only invoking
you know that we i might not trust
michael you know because i don't know
you but i trust god and therefore i'm
going to put this on my currency because
everybody agrees on that so there's
stories that go along with it
i think part of the techno technological
superiority
is not enough you know people need a
story and this is coming along nicely
before i do want to move away from
blockchain to get into your concepts
about higher education
uh and some some ideas that i find
fascinating look i think we should
address the issue of blockchain which is
which is first of all every every fiat
currency in history
has been debased and eventually failed
so
if you're going to be an academic or
you're going to be historian
you can't find a single example
of of sound money everlasting
anywhere on earth no commodity money
no gold money no silver no copper no
fiat
no nothing you cannot find as you can't
find a single regime that ever
executed a strong money policy for 25
years straight in the history of man
so when we say you know when satoshi
said you know
the problem with fiat currency is all
the trusted requires from banks and
and they've always betrayed trust he was
just pointing out the obvious
every bank on earth can print more money
with impunity
and every central bank can print more
money it's just an observation
and so so the idea that you should
actually create a monetary system based
upon
trust of a banker or a politician
is uh is about a silly notion
as the idea that you should sail a ship
across the atlantic with leaks in it
without making sure there no
do you trust the boat to not have leaks
in it and or do you like make sure it's
leak proof
no i mean every pilot does it every
pilot does a preflight
there's no engineering system that
functions with a leak
your swimming pool doesn't would you
jump into your swimming pool without
checking see if there's water in the
swimming pool
would you actually jump into a swimming
pool with a leak in it
like the swimming pool won't work the
airplane won't fly
the ship won't sail the
electrical system won't work with the
short circuit the pneumatic
system won't work with a leak in it you
know nothing
works in the engineering world if you
don't have
you know integrity and a closed system
and nothing works in math if you just
change the number right i mean the point
is math is math so
if you want to reject all of math all of
thermodynamics all of science
the conservation of energy in the
universe then yeah
you can run your society based upon fiat
currency with one individual that makes
up however much money they want to make
up at any given time
but it seems pretty clear that the rest
of the universe
doesn't work that way and so being
against the idea of a blockchain
that actually enforces integrity
and enforces mathematical scarcity and
conservation of energy
being against that is like being against
the laws of gravity being against the
passage of time and being against
math right and there are politicians
that are against conservation of energy
the passage of time
and math right there are plenty of
examples
but there are no successful engineers
and so i i think that that what can be
said about blockchain is it's an
engineered monetary network
it it's the reason the asset class is
outperforming
other every other asset over every time
period since its instantiation
is because it's mathematically pure and
everything else
is subject to debasement and dilution
and
inflation and and any
engineer or mathematician or scientist
with any degree of integrity
would look at that accept it and say
yeah
i think i'm going to design my system
you know
bowing to newton's laws the laws of math
the laws of thermodynamics the laws of
electrodynamics as best as i understand
them
before finally would you put your
children
into an airplane designed by an engineer
that that did brag to you that he
ignored
the laws of thermodynamics and he broke
all the rules in the airplane
just to improvise yeah would you
improvise
would you cross a bridge designed by an
engineer that bragged that he broke all
the laws and he didn't respect
people with math that checked his
calculus and
he wanted to make up two plus two equals
16.
like the point is nobody in the
civilization would trust
anybody or anything designed by
a not by a politician that simply made
up
the rules and reversed gravity and yet
we trust monetary systems where the
rules are made up
and you can reverse when you have
negative interest rates that's like
reversing the flow of time
you're trying to make time flow
backwards
right good luck with that right right
your family your life your livelihood
to a system that's engineered without
respect for the laws of thermodynamics
the answer is no not a third grader not
i mean
the stupidest person on the planet
probably is not that
stupid i think people just
here's the here's the paradigm shift
they don't realize that we have
engineered
a monetary system for the first time in
human history that actually will work
and they think that they're trapped in
all of the
defective paper political
and commodity monetary systems of the
past and since none of them work
they resign themselves to living in a
world where
nothing works and nothing is going to
work and then what happens next is a
moral hazard where you have one group of
people
run to take control of the banks and the
printing press to enrich their friends
and their pet causes
and another group of people suffer and
starve to death
you know because they don't control the
money
and that's the world we live in today
and that's why this is a moral
issue i want to uh just make a quick
analogy and again i there's so much
about your
educational you know innovation that i
want to get to but
i can't resist this so if you i don't
know if you've ever done this but if you
go to wikipedia pick any wikipedia page
i'm going to pick the wikipedia page of
michael j saylor
and it's an exercise that's fun to do
you click on the first
hyperlink in each page that's unique so
the first one under michael j
sailer is microstrategy click
microstrategy
you go down it goes to data analysis it
goes to cleansing i don't know why
it goes to scrubbing database table
records eventually it gets to abstract
abstract means concept and eventually
almost every single one
if not every single wikipedia page is
fundamentally going to refer to
a single page called philosophy in other
words philosophy
is the core element of every page on
wikipedia at its core
so it goes to ibm it goes to
multinational corporation i've done
this before you came on the show
eventually it goes down to groups
abstract and then you know it gets
totally abstracted away from you and
michael's microstrategy
my thought is that well the reason that
the dollar has power
is because at its core the united states
dollar is backed by eight
nuclear-powered carrier battle groups
and we have this you know immense
military capability and and
throughout history there haven't been
many empires that were the
uh you know reserve currency that didn't
have the most powerful military in the
world being before the u.s it was
england
you know now you know china's kind of on
the rise etc they all have power
it's not like you have some you know
switzerland is going to have the reserve
currency of the world obviously they
have
financial transactions but what is the
core of
of bitcoin or blockchain if you keep
going into the wikipedia page
abstractly you know what is the core of
it because it's not backed by
nine nuclear-powered but you know uh
aircraft carriers
um so what is you know the fundamental
reason
uh that that gives it this protection
that that that really the dollar has
enjoyed for
for you know a long time uh and and then
i think i do want to move off of
blockchain and bitcoin too you're more
your personal philosophy
of life first of all the dollar is only
as old as
1971 right we've got a fiat currency for
50 years number one number two it's lost
98 percent or
90 something percent of its purchasing
power in those 50 years
so like it's not
it has power like
the roman julius caesar had power where
is he today i mean the point is
that babylon had power the the british
empire had
power right napoleon had power
lots of examples of empires that had
you know alexander the great had power
how'd that work out
right the carthaginians of the
phoenicians had power the venetians had
power
the roman catholic church had power
henry the eighth had power
right i don't dispute the fact that they
all had power
everybody has power over the course of
some period of time
and you know the u.s dollar is the
reserve currency of the world it's
undisputable and once i almost wrote a
book all about the supremacy of the
dollar i get it
that's not the point right the point is
is not is it is it the reserve currency
of the world and and do we need to
accommodate it we do
the point is what will
you as an individual choose to use as
your technology
to avoid starving to death or freezing
to death economically
that's the question the argentine
peso had power still has power it
doesn't change the fact that if you live
in argentina you will starve to death
and lose your family's life savings
every 10 years
unless you adopt a new technology right
doesn't change that fact you worry about
it and so the significance of bitcoin is
it's a technology for you to avoid
becoming impoverished right
if i drop you in the middle of russia
the ruble will have power
you know and they will shoot you in the
head if you don't use the robot properly
it doesn't change the question at hand
if you have if you have tuberculosis
you should use penicillin to avoid dying
and if you have a bunch of money in a
country
where the currency is collapsing you
should use bitcoin to avoid
dying right and you know
and if you if i drop you in the middle
of the ocean you should hope you have a
ship around you to avoid
dying right it's just the technology in
order to
live your life in this particular case
and
so what is the core essence of it well
the essence of it
is the same the same thing that makes
the universe
work the laws of thermodynamics and the
conservation of energy
right what's at the core of bitcoin
is the laws of thermodynamics and the
conservation of energy
if i put a million
dollars of monetary energy into the
network in the year 2020
i can go forward 250 years or 50 years
or 10 years or whatever amount of time
frame you want
and i will have the same amount of
monetary energy
scaled up perfectly linearly
you know for the economic growth without
any individual stealing at all if you
take the same amount of monetary energy
and you put it into the dollar you will
lose 99
of that energy it will be stolen from
you
by the central bank and the fractional
reserve bankers over the course of
100 years maybe over the course of 10 to
15 years
right if you put that into a gold
network you're going to lose 90 percent
of the energy if not all of it you'll
lose 90
because of mining and you're likely to
lose the rest when the bank you put it
in gets seized in a regime
change and if you look at the top 100
cities in the
in the world over the last 100 years 95
of them had a regime
change that was hostile that would
result in you losing all of your
monetary energy
so the significance of bitcoin is you
can take
a portion of monetary energy you can
store it on a network
that no politician no bank no
counterparty can seize from you
against your will and nobody can debase
or inflate away
via some some political edict
which is not the case with any other
monetary system on earth
another way to say it is as ross stephen
says
he says you have a choice you can choose
the fiat standard
which is a standard where other people
can print unlimited units of
of money just not you right
you can or you can choose the bitcoin
standard where nobody can print
units of money including you you have a
choice you can live in a world where
someone you don't know
can can rob you of all of your economic
power without your consent without your
knowledge
or you can live in a world where nobody
can
you choose right that's the stark
decision
by the way that's the case
why is this why is this more because
when you live in the universe
you have to subject yourself to the laws
of thermodynamics
you don't get to create energy or
destroy energy or create mass or destroy
there's a conservation of this stuff you
can't leap a million gazillion miles
we don't have a world where you get to
leap a million miles an hour and
murder everybody and the guy next to you
doesn't
right you're both subject to the same
laws of thermodynamics
in that world but in the world of fiat
there's one dude
that can steal the life work of a
billion people
in a minute on a whim
and there's another person that can't
that can have all of their life's energy
sucked out of
their account and be and be rendered a
pulper
that's the world you live in when you
live in a fiat world
and uh you know it seems quite evident
which world
a scientist or an engineer or a rational
thinker
or a person that simply wanted to live
would want to live in you'd want to live
in the thermodynamically sound world of
truth
and integrity and that's at the core
when people question bitcoin it's like
why would you question a monetary
network based upon math
and the laws of thermodynamics that are
that are what god uses to move the
universe
yeah i'm certainly a fan of the laws of
thermodynamics as a physics professor
let me let me ask now on the other side
um so there's people selling bitcoins
uh even though it's today you hit an
all-time high i found out earlier today
it was a forty thousand dollars per
bitcoin
it's up 100 percent in a month um
and uh you know i'm not gonna ask you
for investment advice but i
but i will note you know as again i've
had on bill perkins
you may know uh i've had on jim simons
as i mentioned patrick that david
you know several billionaires and and
billionaire class people and now
now having you on uh what is in your
mind
how do you think about wealth um a lot
of my listeners
criticize me you know for for you know
talking to
billionaires and uh obviously i'm only
talking to people that have something
valuable to say to a technologically uh
astute audience like my audience
um even if they may not be able to you
know construct the theory of everything
themselves
they're keen on these big existential
issues of
that are give meaning to life but how do
you michael how do you think about
wealth what is the purpose of wealth you
know i mean i've i've seen jim simons i
know he has
a yacht you know but as as you know
gordon gekko was told by charlie sheen's
character and
in wall street you know you can only
water ski behind one yacht at a time
what is the purpose of wealth to you
so
money is monetary energy
monetary energy is the apex of all
energies i can i can convert
kinetic energy and i convert potential
energy
and nuclear energy and electrical energy
you know
and even mass into energy right i mean i
can convert
anything into energy anything that i
convert into energy
i can monetize i can take a hundred
million dollars of electricity and make
it a hundred million dollars of money
and that becomes wealth i am a wealthy
person with a hundred million dollars of
energy
i can take a hundred million dollars of
money i can convert it back into
an army of uh whatever five thousand
guys with machine guns and have them
charge off and i can generate kinetic
energy
and chemical energy and i can kill a
bunch of people and chaos
right and so wealth is money
money is energy at the end of the day
energy is is conserved uh it's all there
you can do what you will with it uh
everybody
chooses to channel their energy uh
however they will you can channel your
energy to create amazon
and deliver people you can create a
netflix
you can uh you can endow a park
for example i i happen to be pretty big
into
conservation and i like i like green
space when i see a park
like uh i see a park in um the middle of
naples and it's overrun and it's and
it's not maintained it makes me very sad
so i'm also aware it costs money
it takes wealth to actually maintain a
park it's it's not
cheap to actually do the forestry you
have to continually
work on that uh you can endow a
university
right um i have a non-profit foundation
and uh we operate uh a website
the sailor academy and we give away free
college education
to to people i think seven eight hundred
thousand people last i checked
and uh our goal is to give away
education for free to everybody forever
okay so that that's an interesting thing
it takes energy
right it takes energy you got to create
the courses you got to host the courses
you have to deal with the politics you
have to jump through the hoops to get
ace accredited
right now we're working uh to get
certified
to grant certain types of degrees takes
more energy you have to pay people to do
things
so wealth is just uh energy and you can
channel it however you want
and it ultimately it gets channeled
based upon the values
of the people with the energy right some
wealth is controlled by politicians
right so they can create a central park
right rockefeller had a lot of wealth
and you can trace his fingerprints right
the grand teton national park the the
national park at st
john's in the u.s virgin islands you can
look at all the state parks up and down
the hudson river
that were contributed by wealthy
individuals like rockefeller and jp
morgan
some people you know harvard was endowed
by whatever harvard and a bunch of
wealthy people they wanted a university
so the issue is what are your values
cathedrals were built by wealthy people
to the glory of god
you know there's plenty of hospitals
that are endowed by the wealthy so
i think that wealth is energy to be
channeled how you will
whether or not you have religious values
political values environmental values or
family values or
whatever you want to do with it people
do with it
as you said earlier you know you can't
you jump
800 times higher than michael jordan
just because you think you can
but as you know from your engineering
background uh
that you know money uh money being
essentially this this form of energy
the rate at which energy is consumed is
power is the
actual definition of the watt power um
and so there are listeners that ask me
you know how can i talk to people that
have
so much power the ability to convert
energy
and do work in a very brief amount of
time those obviously you're not gonna
construct a mercenary army i hope you
know with with some of your money but
it's not on my agenda it would be a bad
investment anyway
because you're competing right here
there's a government army that's
subsidized by the government
and they give it away for free why would
you want to try to compete with that
all right you heard it here first
michael saylor is not going to construct
a private mercenary army that would be
you know kind of the start of many many
sci-fi dystopian futures but
but the point that you know one of my
listeners asked me is like i interviewed
these people that have all this power
but never has there been such
discrepancy in power so yes
you can have more energy you can have
more money but we're also living in
the most polarized you know discrepancy
between
those that can apply energy in the
shortest amount of time
and those that cannot um how how do you
does that affect you do you think about
that um
uh you know obviously there will be
discrepancies with there were no
discrepancies that thermodynamics would
not uh
you can do extraction of zero users look
i do think about i think the people the
most power the politicians and the
bankers right
you know like we have people in the
world that actually can spend
5 trillion a year
what private citizen do you know that
can spend a trillion in a year
right nobody right the fed buys 120
billion worth of bonds a month
tell give me one private individual that
can spend 120 billion dollars a month
so so the truth is we have a big big
power discrepancy
the politicians have the most power then
you have you have
others that have power the number one
source of the power discrepancy
is the fiat standard and that's why
bitcoin is the solution
right the solution to actually uh to
stopping the conte
the cantillon effect right the fact is
when i print a trillion dollars
and i use it to buy certain assets i buy
them
from people that i wish to buy them from
and if you hold those assets
like bonds if you own you know the best
trade this year was owning long-term
government bonds you got a 20
return on that that's because you sold
them to the government
no reasonable person would have bought
that so go
go figure how many hundreds of billions
of dollars flowed
because certain people traded with
certain other people
so i you know the reason that bitcoin is
the solution is
if you can take the power to create
when you create if i have 25 trillion
dollars of currency floating around
and i just print another trillion i just
seized four percent
of all the power in the civilization and
i just did it
by fiat right by edict without even a
law being passed
right so so the biggest power
discrepancy is is the current
uh power to print money currency
and that leads to all the other power
discrepancies and if you want to reverse
that
then you need you need to educate the
world so that people understand that
they should switch
from the fiat standard to the bitcoin
standard because
if you're on the bitcoin standard nobody
could print more bitcoin
and deprive you of your monetary energy
right it's so it's it's really critical
thing right i mean everything relates to
everything
in a society where i mean go to zimbabwe
right in a society where one dictator
takes over the entire country and starts
printing
pretty soon there's only 22 people in
the country that have enough to eat and
everybody else is impoverished i mean
you want you want real power discrepancy
right it's it's as the as the government
prints more and more
currency when i print twice as much
currency i've seized half of all
assets right that's what's happened when
i print ten times more currency
i've seized ninety percent of all assets
so there's not so so the biggest power
shift
and wealth discrepancy is coming about
uh based because of like modern monetary
theory
and this thought that it's it's okay for
the government
to print infinite money it's okay i
think it's you know as the
cain said you know not one man and a
million can detect the
inflationary perniciousness that is
unleashed i know you don't have too much
more time michael but i do want to get
to some give a few more minutes to talk
about sailor academy
you're a pilot um like me private pilot
um
first of all what's your dream plane in
your hangar what's your dream hanger
look like
i have a global express i like it i'm
gonna keep it
are you type rated in it no i don't fly
it i used to fly i mean i learned to fly
when i was in the air force and i
yeah and uh i just you know
it takes a lot of time and energy to
keep up with that and it's not
safe yeah to be a hobbyist in that
a lot of a lot of wealthy people died
crashing their own airplane
and so i don't really wish to emulate
that model i'm just perfectly fine
being flung being a passenger but when
you were training and you were learning
how to fly
obviously there's some of that you can
learn online like
john and martha king you may remember
them from your training uh they're here
in san diego
friends of mine they run king schools um
but uh you can take their on that
subject i will say i think it'd be
really cool if we get to the point
where we have the tesla of airplanes if
we can create an electric
electric-powered hovercraft
airplane maybe a four-person airplane
that's electric powered even if it was
low
altitude where you could zip around at
20 30 50 or 100 feet up
yeah that would be really really neat
yeah your
fraternity brother peter has talked to
me about that exact
exact point um but getting back to you
know what it actually took to become a
pilot
and so the kings john and martha king
say you know once you become a pilot
even the day you get your first solo
under your belt
your identity has changed you are now
part of
an elite core of human beings who have
flown
an aircraft sat in a chair above the
ground moving at 100 miles an hour
and live to tell about it some of that
you can learn
online but a lot of it you can't and you
need to have your flight instructor it
needs to be taught from apprentice to
to uh you know to protege so or to to
from mentor to protege
so my question to you is you know can
can you have
um you know online education
uh for example your alma mater has all
of its courses open
and yet they're 10 times oversubscribed
talk about you know
uh constrained supply the the the
president of mit has said that he could
uh
accept ten times as many people without
changing the quality one bit
uh and so therefore they have this open
courseware etc
but um but is it the same you know is it
the same to take the open courseware is
there
something that sailor academy can't
provide
um you know online learning versus
online
education or credentialism there's a
difference what do you think is the most
important problem to solve and that
you're directing sailor academy's
efforts towards
i think if you look at the disciplines
of mathematics
computer science a lot of the
engineering's
a lot of general science the ones that
don't require extreme
lab work um i mean math is perfect
example right you don't need lab work
for math computer science you don't need
lab or you're on a computer
so they're they're obvious but but um
if you look at the science and
technology and engineering disciplines
i think that they'd lend themselves well
to online uh
automated education uh i don't think
ballet
and banjo playing is quite as good
right i mean and scuba diving and
piloting
not quite as good but yeah there are
flight simulators which are interesting
yeah but but the obvious is just uh
computer science data science and
mathematics
and what i think there is
i think someone said i mean we spend
billions of dollars a year
paying calculus teachers you really need
like
what 10 superstar teachers of cal maybe
one two three four
somewhere between two and uh
twelve good teachers and then you need
to capture their courseware
yeah you know online and then i don't
know why they couldn't teach the next
billion people
or 10 billion people why can't 12
you know i mean you talked about isaac
newton a lot right isaac newton wrote
principia mathematic and as far as i can
see isaac newton must have like invented
like 80 percent of all the math that
anybody ever needs
ever and maybe i i think probably
it's it's probably not unreasonable to
say that someone on the order of 98 to
99
of all human beings don't know as much
math as isaac newton laid out might be
99.9 percent of all human beings
didn't didn't outstrip what i mean if
isaac newton was alive today he could
have taught
everything that 99.9
of the people would have needed to know
and 300 years after he's gone we still
haven't
outrun calculus of variations and all
these other
things he did you know what he claimed
was his biggest accomplishment michael
what that he died a virgin because he
was intensely religious and he wanted to
emulate
christ in every way but that wasn't his
biggest accomplishment no
i'm just saying that was what he was
most proud of apparently anyway getting
back to he was probably being
politically correct in some sort
1730s version yes but but science and
technology clearly you can automate that
if we want to move the civilization
forward
we got like 10 million phds we need a
billion phds
yeah you you're not going to come up
with you know
interstellar travel and nuclear fusion
on a sugar cube and new propulsion
and cures to cancer with um
undergraduate degrees
sure you're gonna i got paid to go to i
got paid to go to graduate school as a
graduate
as teaching assistant a fellowship uh
whereas you know undergraduate i had to
get loans or get get
it doesn't change the fact right that we
need a billion phds right right so how
do you incentivize that
how do you well so the first point is it
cost a million dollars to create a phd
if you do it
you know the old-fashioned way you need
to do it for a nickel
right you need to drive the cost of
education down to a nickel and the way
to do that
is to is to upload all the computer
science and math and physics and
engineering
curriculum from k all the way through
phd
everything that can possibly be taught
needs to be uploaded
and made free and then people need to be
able to go with their own
at their own pace well you you can't
really
convince me that i need to have a
hundred and eighty seven thousand
geometry teachers in the world or
or i don't need a world of a million
calculus
teachers i don't even need a calculus
teacher sitting in front of me
i don't need a person to teach me math i
mean it's just it's it's it's a silly
two plus two equals four you gotta be
here
or the computer can teach me the math so
i think i don't think i don't see any
reason why we can't take
98 of the cost
of education and dematerialize it just
uploaded
if you go to if you go to my website and
you start taking the physics course
you'll actually see lectures by walter
lewin and walter lewin is standing in
the same lecture hall
where he taught me he's the same guy
that taught me the same course
in the same lecture hall in the video
the difference is
the amount of money i paid mit or that
that had to be paid to mit
for me to sit in that room with 300
other freshmen
impoverished my family in eight weeks
in eight weeks it was our our entire
family's life savings everything we
saved in 200 freaking years
was the cost to go through half a
semester at mit
you can have the entire thing for free
and by the way it's better
it's better and i'm not sitting in the
back of the lecture hall you're up front
you can start it you can stop it you can
speed it up
so the real point here is
there's no reason why we can't give
everybody unlimited free education
as much as they want as fast as they can
have it and if
and they can go as far as they want to
go and the cost of education is divided
into three components right
there's the foo the room and board the
food cost
and that's universal basic income so if
the society wants to give people
food and room and board for the rest of
their life i'm okay with it we're
kind of doing it anyway right now the
second component is the country club
component
like we're going to let you play flag
football and go spelunking and be in the
glider club
and maybe meet friends and have dances
and
you know and have frat parties or
whatever you know and i'll play golf on
the golf team
that's the country club element maybe
the society wants to pay for that or not
i mean it's another political decision
and the third element is the part where
they teach you stuff
the third element we can de-materialize
to literally be the cost of electricity
i don't i mean i don't see any reason
why if you took
point one percent of the department of
education's annual budget
you could upload pretty much every
science technology and engineering
course and give it away to 8 billion
people for free and all they have to do
is buy a used ipad
or a used computer and pay for
electricity and bandwidth
and we're going there i mean we're not
getting that support from the government
i mean
and uh most of the universities they're
more the problem is
they're they're creating scarcity and
the
certificate are in the diploma because
their business model
is great scarcity but i actually think
that what we're going to find
is that um the diploma is going to
become less valuable
if i could actually give you a test and
test whether or not you understood math
i wouldn't care whether you had a phd in
math
i wouldn't care whether you you know if
you told me you had a phd in math from
harvard and you had all a grades
but if you flunked my assessment i
wouldn't hire you
and if you told me you'd never gone to
school but if you were the best out of a
hundred thousand people
at the assessment i would hire you so i
think we're going through a rotation
from the appearance of
skill and acumen to the actual essence
of skill and acumen the only reason that
we rely upon degrees is because it's too
expensive
to assess to a say talent
yeah but the reason it's expensive to
save talent is because we don't have an
automated way to do it
but what if i told you we did like what
if i actually gave you
when you apply for a job with me
i give you a test in analytics a test in
english a test in engineering a test and
whatever and i just run that with a
robot
and if you pass the test and if you're
the top one out of a million people
i don't care that you got a d from a
community college or you didn't go or
you did go
i don't care that you know i don't care
anything other than fight you can do the
job
and we're we're moving toward that world
so that that world is a world where
you're going to see
you're going to see a disruption of the
traditional education establishment
you're already seeing it you're going to
see more of it i mean when it when an
ivy league school
charges you 50 000 or 30 000 tuition
to study online over zoom yeah
let me give you another secret right you
can go on youtube
and you can go to the basic the original
sources and you can bypass
you know why do i want to learn but
here's an interesting question
i'm the ceo of a publicly traded company
i've been doing it for 22 years i got 30
years experience
i will sit and tell you how to run a
publicly traded company
why would you want to go to business
school pay 50 000
and have a professor that has never run
a publicly traded company
that read books written by a guy that's
never on a publicly traded company
talk to you about how to run a publicly
traded company like
just like why do i want to learn
math from the 800 000
best you think the people teaching
calculus
like in you know in the 800
000 you know public elementary or public
high school do you think that person is
the best calculus
i always say that like you know
practitioner in the world
turn down ucsd and go to harvard
uh and i say do you think that they you
know know some
you know fourth fifth sixth law of
thermodynamics that like we haven't
learned yet in uc san diego
it's a public institution and a very
good one at that
i want to take it a step further if
you'll indulge me um why not you know
instead of learning from michael saylor
or let's put it this way getting back to
my friend isaac newton
again uh you know who would you rather
learn calculus from so isaac newton has
you know 800
000 words that he's written down i'm
sure you're aware of this software gpt-3
and all these artificial intelligence
codes so it turns out that that people
like him like my
my personal hero galileo over here i'll
send you a little finger puppet sometime
yeah so galileo he wrote the best book
probably written in popular science ever
written called the dialogue on two world
systems i had never read it until i was
a
18th year professor and at at ucsd
and and it's all his philosophy and he's
a wonderful writer he talks about like
why not learn directly from him yeah and
just dump this in to gp3
and then i don't have to like even just
wait for you to put out your master
class
i can anytime i want in my pajamas learn
from galileo from
uh from albert einstein from gnome yeah
whoever you want to learn from
uh but it will be synthetic and and the
question is is it just conventionalism
like
i mean people are paying for this this
this notion
of you know the superiority of the
harvard degree
and and having that credentialism do you
see that collapsing as
as you foresaw back in 2012 the collapse
and dem
materialization of currency of you know
virtualization process do you see that
occurring
thanks to artificial intelligence i do i
i do like
at what rate unclear what rate but
absolutely collapsing
like i what we didn't get to when i
talked about the implication of the
virtual wave the implication of the
virtual wave is that you need one
really great communicator and the other
800 000 mediocre ones
don't have a job anymore like like uh
during the lockdown there's
there is a family the petersons and they
they blew to prominence on youtube they
have 800 000
views it's the perfect family
like they're all beautiful they're all
talented
they all get along with each other the
music is great
they play well it's well produced
they give it away for free and they've
got fans everywhere in the world
and here's what i thought i thought well
there could be no family that perfect
right like they could but then i
realized well they're they're the one in
a million families that is that perfect
right
and then i thought you know there used
to be 27 000 local bands playing to 200
people in a pub
and they're all out of business because
the pubs got shut down
and everybody's sitting at home watching
this perfect family on youtube
playing in super high def and for them
to
to become superstars 20 000
decent average musicians had to lose
everything
had to be suppressed and what you're
describing is
you know why don't we just go to the
first to the source now by the way
maybe galileo and isaac newton are the
two best people to teach
but you know maybe isaac newton was not
a good teacher but there is somewhere in
the
somewhere in the last 300 years it is
the beauty of like the youtube algorithm
is
they'll figure out the best one yeah
right when you go to youtube
they will find the most beautiful family
they will find the best t
they will find they will find the most
entertaining
whatever so match it to you right
they'll match it to your
click rate your yeah and and
you know there's a certain degree of
immortality we're going to get
starting in the 21st century right isaac
newton didn't have the ability to
upload all of his lectures feynman did
by the way right feynman's lectures
there's a lot of stuff that was
videotaped in the 60s 70s and 80s
yeah it's now finding its way to youtube
and is not going to die ever
and some of it's really good yeah like
you'll find
like you know i'll find my hero maybe
robert heinlein one of my favorite
authors he gave a speech
at a science fiction conference whatever
in 1970 or whenever and i can go back
and i can be a fly on the wall and watch
him speak
even though and i feel like this is
great i'm moving through time and space
to go back in time to see
something that happened when i was just
barely born yeah
and i think 500 years from now
right maybe that will last we we have
the music of beethoven because we can
perfectly reproduce it
right and there's nothing produced by
any composer in the last hundred years
that's worth listening to
compared to beethoven i'd just rather
just go back rewind
and i think i think you'll see the same
how is her copyright on principia
mathematica right it's 200 years old
there's not
99 percent of what you need to know she
probably shouldn't be copyrighted no
it's not
actually that's it's funny that you
mentioned it for this book so this book
is translated by stillman drake i don't
know if you can see it the forwards by
some guy named albert einstein who calls
it
perhaps the greatest book of popular
science so to speak that was ever
written
and he was known to write some books
this book exists it's existed for
for almost 400 years you can i've seen
an original copy my friend
jay pasikoff professor at williams
college in massachusetts
owns an original copyright williams
college does
and this book you turn it it's pages are
history
that book is more um available
in almost every other form except no
one's ever made an audiobook version of
it
can i download it to ibooks it's not you
can't get an electronic version of it in
this particular translation you can get
ahead of me salivating right now i feel
like i want it but the way i want it is
i just want to download it to my ipad
you cannot do it that's so what i'm
doing michael and uh
i'd love to involve it it's a good and
you would think that google would have
done that as part of the gutenberg
it doesn't exist so this is the
definitive translation stillman drake
professor at university of california is
dead now but
this is from 1957. i am with an italian
physicist colleague
or tr are making not only the
translation of it but we're actually
recording the audiobook
so you'll be able to get this and i'm
not doing it for profit i don't care
about the problem
you're resonating with this man's mind
that's 400 years old and i should point
out that this is a case where technology
is kind of um the progression of
technology actually was detrimental
because
this book is cheaper than darwin's
origin of species
and the reason why is because of
technology darwin's
origin of species written 200 years
after it should be cheaper right
it's actually much more rare because it
was printed on paper not
parchment like the original version of
this paper has acid in it
the paper was causing it to disintegrate
but it made the characters wider
brighter the paint on the page
left off the page more and so in that
case technology is actually bad and it's
more rare more valuable to have
a copy of origin of species than to have
an original dialogue by galileo which
200 years older anyway i thought that
was a cute tidbit but
i am taking this book and my goal is
before i he actually has another book
which i think i'd love to send you a
copy of michael
um if you'll give me your address it's
called the military compass
and you're like what the hell is this
it's actually one of his first books if
not his first book 1600 he wrote it
and in it he talks about this compass is
really a slide rule and they called it a
compass
and as you mit beavers love or fonder
your slide rules
but in it he goes through all the cool
things you can do with the military
compass including
currency conversions and i want to
finish up with this before i ask you
these three questions i ask all my
guests but in the currency conversion
section he goes let's say you've got
venetian scooty
and you want to convert it to um to
florentine ducati
or whatever i forget what it is and he
goes through the exercise of how you use
a slide roll to
you know this is the people in 1600
before calculus and whatever
so the slide rule that he invented uh he
really wrote the instruction manual for
it
and and he goes through and i'm thinking
as i'm reading this book which is also
doesn't exist in electronic form doesn't
exist in
audiobook form so that's another one
it's only 50 pages long
but anyway when um when you read it i'm
thinking i'm just like i want to shake
him i'm like galileo
take this book which there's only like
100 copies left in the whole planet
of his compass book it's even more rare
than the dialogue
and i said galileo in my dream shaking
him
put these books away because in 400
years no one's going to care about
a scooty a billion scooty a trillion
ducati because you can't do anything
with it
but one copy of your book it'll be worth
18 million dollars
and if you just put it asset it is
a scarce asset it is a scarce asset so
michael um
i know your time you've been so generous
i hope we can do maybe a part two
i want to maybe pick your brain with uh
with a friend of a friend
uh named peter thiel um who uh who i've
met
and uh has similar ideas about education
and i think
it would be fun to have a conversation
be a fly on the wall digital fly on the
wall
if i can set that up with you it's it's
refreshing to talk to you
and to get a glimpse of of of the future
perhaps and your thought process and to
hear your
uh very intellectually honest
perspective on on life and and
everything i hope we could do a part two
maybe
maybe that will be in the in the
comments be fun i'd be happy to
that'd be great thank you put it
together and i'll be there i enjoyed our
our discussion thanks for having me
me too thank you i'm sorry to interrupt
this video but i have to
say you're going to not want to miss
michael sandler's
answers to the questions of what he
would put on a monolith
that would last for a billion years what
his last will and testament will be of
the ethical variety
and also you won't want to miss what he
would tell
a younger version of michael saylor to
have the courage to go into the
impossible these are the thrilling three
final questions i ask
all my cherished guest but to get access
to michael's answers you're gonna have
to subscribe to my newsletter
at briankeating.com it's uh it's been a
blast i've had tons of tons of new
followers and this is a great way for me
to connect with you
offer a free giveaways like a signed
book
by michael and by other people uh that
we've had on the podcast
it's a way for me to connect with you so
i don't want you to miss the answers
that he gives his most vulnerable
most incisive answers i've ever heard
him give personally
a little bit biased because i asked them
but he's an amazing intellect you don't
want to miss his answers please sign up
i won't spam you you get one email a
week with the tips and tricks
from the brightest minds in the
multiverse
so join up and you'll get those answers
brian keating.com
thanks i'll see you over there
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
you